[Musique]
fait lui juste passer l'année
fait lui juste passer l'année on me
parle là de teva un petit garçon que
j'allais accueillir dans ma classe je ne
le connaissais pas encore mais on venait
de me l'étiqueter comme cancres
pourquoi parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à se
démarquer dans les deux intelligences
les plus mises en avant dans notre
système éducatif
l'intelligence verbal linguistique qui
est notre capacité à maîtriser les
structures des langues et l'intelligence
logico mathématique qui est notre
capacité à calculer
ordonnée et comparer
howard gardner a défini huit différents
types d'intelligence
8 et j'adore la métaphore de bruno oust
qui dit que nous naissons tous avec ses
8 fleurs d'intelligence
vif le que nous arrosons tous les jours
grâce à nos actions avec notre entourage
et notre environnement
si nous pouvons arroser nos fleurs
il y en a comme dans n'importe quel
jardin qui sont bien plus développée que
les autres des fleurs qui sont plus
grandes que les autres on les appelle
les intelligences dominante
après quelques semaines d'observation
je remarque que teva a pour intelligence
dominante l'intelligence kinesthésique
c'est celle qui nous permet d'être agile
avec notre corps et avec les objets qui
nous entourent
on retrouve cette intelligence notamment
chez les sportifs les mécaniciens mais
également chez les chirurgiens
après des semaines de travail des mois
en commun avec teva et ont reconnu dans
son intelligence dominante a repris
confiance en lui et a pu s'ouvrir aux
autres quand il s'agit notamment ceux
qui sont les plus encensés dans notre
système éducatif
oulalala la veille l'oea ne te laisse
pas faire par cette petite elle a un
sacré caractère
on me parle là de ti allez une petite
fille de 5 ans que j'allais avoir dans
ma classe
si on peut arroser nos fleurs
d'intelligence faut les faire grandir il
arrive malheureusement quand n'en
délaissent on ne s'occupe pas du tout
d'elle et après quelques jours
d'observation je remarque que lafleur
d'intelligence intra personnel de d'y
aller n'est encore qu'à l'état de pouce
or c'est une fleur importante et
nécessaire à stimuler dès le plus jeune
âge parce qu'elle nous permet de prendre
confiance en nous de nous connaître de
nous fixer des objectifs à atteindre
et de prendre en main notre vie et nos
apprentissages
comment demander à une enfant de 5 ans
en plein combat intérieur d'apprendre à
lire et à écrire
après des mois de travail beaucoup de
patience mais surtout beaucoup beaucoup
d'amour thialé a développé sa fleur
d'intelligence intra personnel elle a
repris confiance en elle elle était plus
posé et a pu s'ouvrir aux apprentissage
de la lecture et de l'écriture
une autre intelligence qui est très
importante à stimuler et à développer
dès le plus jeune âge et l'intelligence
inter personnelles
c'est l'intelligence qui nous permet
d'entrer en relation avec les autres
je me rappelle d'un atelier à l'école
des élèves devaient faire un exercice de
lecture et pour valider leur 6 il devait
se faire filmer par un élève pas filmer
se faire prendre en photo par un élève
et là ma grande surprise j'ai vu mon
petit michel cinq ans
s'épanouir complètement il est allé bien
au delà de ce qui lui était demandé car
il n'a pas fait que prendre en photo ses
camarades il les a guidés il les a
conseillés et il les a encouragés à ne
serait-ce que commencer exercice
michel qui semblait complètement perdu
complètement
passifs dans ses apprentissages et est
devenu acteur parce qu'il pouvait
évoluer dans ce domaine dans cette
intelligence qui lui était propre
il a pu ainsi aider ses camarades et
s'aider lui-même
ce que j'adore avec la théorie des
intelligences multiples sait que rien
n'est fixé rien n'est figé comme dans un
jardin les fleurs évoluent au gré des
saisons
victorien la première fois que je les ai
vus dans ma classe elle avait 5 ans et
son intelligence dominante était
l'intelligence verbal linguistique
gelé revue cinq ans plus tard et à ma
grande surprise elle avait développé une
autre intelligence
elle évoluer dans un espace qu'elle ne
connaissait que depuis cinq minutes
pour un jeu elle avait les yeux bandés
devaient marcher retrouver ses camarades
qui frappait dans des cailloux
et je les ai vus
évoluer sereinement
marché se diriger
ok là via le mieux donc ça veut dire que
l'escalier et là ok
et donc
ok et à voile à la fin et la up
elle avait développé sans intelligence
visio spatiales
c'est l'intelligence qui nous permet de
nous représenter le monde dans toutes
ses dimensions
en la retour notamment chez les peintres
les sculpteurs
mais également chez les architectes
lors de ce jeu victorien n'a pas fait
que stimuler de façon ludique sans
intelligence visio spatiales
elle a également stimulé son
intelligence musicale rythmique
c'est notre capacité à écouter les sons
les reproduire mais également à
ressentir les vibrations
dans toutes les civilisations retrouve
une trace de la musique c'est donc elle
est importante pour l'être humain et
pourtant elles ne représentent qu'une
petite partie d apprentissage à l'école
mon dernier fils à deux ans et demi et
il est plutôt naturaliste
ilham évoluer dehors ils aiment la
nature les plantes les animaux mais
également les étoiles et la lune
c'est d'ailleurs dehors qu'il a voulu
apprendre à marcher
le soir quand il s'endort il veut voir
la lune il veut voir les étoiles
et donc pour l'aider à développer ses
autres intelligence je le laisse évoluer
je prends en considération son
intelligence dominante et petit à petit
je lui apprends le nom des couleurs le
nom des plantes je lui fais remarquer le
bruit de la nature
est ainsi tout se passe bien il est
beaucoup plus serein
ma question en tant que maman
comment ça va se passer quand il sera à
l'école quand on lui demandera de rester
assis à l'intérieur a regardé le tableau
alors qu'il sera préoccupé par ce qu'il
se passe dehors
pourquoi les nuages pourquoi telle
couleur
le petit chat qui est dehors et ce qu'il
à sa maman qu'est ce qui se passe dehors
non il faudra qu'ils restent focalisées
à l'intérieur
ma question en tant que maman
et comment cela va se passer quand on va
le noter ce sa capacité à grimper à un
arbre alors que c'est un magnifique
poisson rouge
merci
[Applaudissements]